[Music]
hello and welcome to this deep dive on
play data if you're ever being in a
situation where you released an app and
realized only days later that you had to
replace it do you appreciate that the
console has great acquisition reports
for in approaches but doesn't offer a
lot of insight for other business models
and have you ever wanted to take a deep
dive into your own data but felt that
our statistic pages were not powerful
enough if you're thinking yes to any of
these we have some great news to share
we recognize that every business and
every role within the business may have
different data needs and we want to make
our data and work for all of you in this
talk you will learn what we've done to
help you monitor your production
releases explore new ways to dig into
your own data and gain new business
insights my name is Suzanne I'm a
product manager on play and I'll be
talking you through the new release
dashboard that we launched yesterday but
first a few introductions hi there my
name is Tamsin Kalin I work for Google
Play business development in a mere hi
I'm Dario I'm one of the engineering
leads on the Play console I focus on
making our analytics matrix finally and
useful to our developers so let's start
let's start with your app releases and
how we're helping you ensure that you
don't leave a bad relationship reduction
any lower than needed with our new low
latency metrics and the release specific
breakdown into your data we're giving
you an hour-by-hour view into your app
release health out-of-the-box without
the need for an SDK this will allow you
to make decisions about the rollout of
your release sooner and with more
confidence we've always been ahead of
the curve with tools to prepare great
releases we have the pre-launch report
we have the alpha and beta
channels but we haven't yet given you
the data to monitor your production
release as it happens we now give you a
product that allows you to look at the
core release metrics in one view the
release dashboard within a couple of
hours of your release entering the
production track you will see data for
that release on the dashboard so when
you push a new release you obviously
care about crashes the crashes that we
used to show where those were a user
proactively reported a crash but we also
now have device reported crashes and
that's the metric that you see here
unless a user opted out during the set
up of their device all crashes are
reported automatically which should mean
a lot more data for you the other metric
you should really care about is a NRS
application not responding these are
events where the Android operating
system reports that your app becomes
unresponsive for five seconds or more
now if on the crash cart you click on
view clusters or on the ANR cards you
click on view ANR's you'll be able to
see if your release introduce any new
crashes or a NR as you should care about
and you can explore the new crash in a
in our metrics there as well so to learn
more about the new crashing in our
metrics and to learn exactly ten secrets
about health metrics please come back to
the same stage as 5:30 p.m. today to see
Fergus Ricardo and Joe talk now back to
the release dashboard so it shows you
crashes and A&Rs
releases aren't all about app health
though you also want to see ratings and
reviews specific to your latest version
when the average rating for your current
release is well we know that of your
overall rating you may want to start
looking into your one and two star
reviews to see what's going wrong and
possibly even move on to holding your
release
but what if you could also see
low-latency
install and uninstall events that are
specific to your release and what if you
could know how many uninstalls
came from updated devices are you losing
existing customers because your new
version doesn't perform installs broken
down by new installs and updates can
tell a powerful story to though have
enough users updated for me to push my
staged rollouts to the next phase
as I started hinting it's not all about
a single metric your crash tool may warn
you if you get a huge spike your p.m.
may tell you of your rating suddenly
drop but what about subtle but
significant changes across the board
would you ever notice if you didn't see
them all in the same place maybe your
crashes go up but not to a point where
you would hold your release just yet but
your ratings are down and if you look
further your uninstalls are becoming
starting to trend above average the
combined data may tell you that this is
not early stage noise but actually a
real problem that you need to
investigate so the context provided by
this holistic review by this holistic
view is precisely how Play data will
help you make decisions sooner and with
more confidence so so far you've seen a
bunch of metrics that tell you a lot
about your production release both were
looked at in isolation what are my
ratings doing and together so what are
my ANR's doing to my uninstalls or to my
ratings i've kept one of the most
powerful features from you though and
that's comparison during user studies we
ran for the release dashboard we we
noticed that virtually every participant
mentioned that the success of a release
is measured relative to the success of a
previous release everybody has their own
idea of what's an acceptable number of
crashes and acceptable rating so release
dashboard when you open it later today
as a selector at the top that
allows you to pick a past release to
compare your current release against so
here is what comparison would look like
for uninstall events and for crashes the
power of comparing is that it gives you
even more signals to increase your
confidence you don't only if your
crashes you don't only have the impact
that your ANR's are having on your
ratings but you can also see how these
metrics compare against the previous
successful release and Jem City
developer of big hits like Fanta pop
cookie Jam and genies and gems confirms
exactly those notions quicker insight
into success or problems and comparing
crashing A&R metrics against the
previous release to see if they need to
start looking into newly introduced
crashes and wish a very popular shopping
app say that they can now ramp up their
releases faster and with more confidence
and respond to issues more intelligently
the head of product also specifically
mentioned that comparing ratings across
releases gave very important qualitative
feedback which ties back to what I
mentioned before about not focusing on
app health alone right that's a relief
dashboard that makes Play data work for
you in low latency so go look for it in
the play console when your next push
your new version out it is a new topmost
item on the release management you'll be
confident sooner and you'll have fewer
users spending time looking at a bad app
release version Thank You Suzanne so
when we think about the apps development
lifecycle clearly the release is a
critical point I don't think anyone
disagrees but once you have your app in
production and you're happy with it
you probably want to drive lots of new
and valuable installs right now given
that you've all heard about the new
release dashboard I have confidence when
you leave i/o
or you'll be able to have a great
release of your app and once you have
your app live what are the four
questions you should be asking yourself
to grow your business you should be
asking which marketing channels are
driving my most valuable users which
countries are they coming from are my
install and buy conversion rates
actually good and which channels are
bringing me my most loyal users so why
is this important and what am I going to
tell you well I'll get onto that in a
second so in my role I talk to
developers every single day probably
some of you in the audience who I speak
to it regularly and what I hear you say
is that you need to know how effective
your marketing channels are for
attracting and retaining new valuable
users I hear you say that you need more
data to make the right decision on where
you spend your money and where you spend
your time and effort to optimize your
growth strategies now you may already
know this but in case you don't a couple
of years ago we launched the user
acquisition report to remind you the
user acquisition report shows you how
many people are going to your Play Store
listing page of those how many people
install your app and of those how many
people buy and buy again you can cut
this report by five main channels the
Play Store Google AdWords Google search
third-party referrers and tracked
channels now since last I oh we've
launched two improvements to this report
just to make it more useful for you and
help you with your growth strategies but
first I want to touch on track channels
and why you should really be using these
today so one of the most powerful
features of the user acquisition report
is the ability to track and see
acquisition broken down by UTM tag now
UTM tag lets you identify a link you've
use to drive traffic to your door
listing page any link you can use UTM
tags your social shares your website
even
other apps and by tagging these links
you can see all of your traffic broken
down by unique identifier wise it's
important well if you're going to spend
money on a campaign you probably want to
know how it's performing and this allows
you to see exactly which link is
contributing to your most valuable users
it's really powerful you can apply this
link to anything you create track the
contribution that that specific link has
had to your growth success so UTM tags
are great for plan campaigns but when I
speak to developers a lot of them tell
me that the majority of their traffic
actually comes organically through the
Play Store I can see some nodding now
you may remember I told you we've made
two improvements to the user acquisition
report so the first one is we've added
country breakdown to the user
acquisition traffic report and this is
really helpful because as you may have
heard earlier today and/or yesterday we
now have two billion android active
devices across the world so this report
helps to identify where your unrealized
opportunity is for internationals
expansion and domination
now let me share with you a case study
of a partner who uses their benefit
concrete software is a Minneapolis based
games company perhaps like you in the
audience or on the live stream
they've run a really lean operation
they've got about 30 people so getting
the right information about their
business quickly so they can act on it
is pretty crucial about a year ago
concrete software we're using the user
acquisition reports for their game
arctic cat which is a snowmobile game
obviously set in a snowy landscape and
they could see that their install
conversion was a little bit lower than
what they'd expected when we launched
country breakdown instantly they could
see why this was the case what they saw
was that countries in cold climates with
snow haddem five times greater in store
conversion
warmer climates that did not have snow
such as Brazil Indonesia etc so suddenly
they realized they should be
concentrating their optimizations on
these cold climate countries which you
can see that they've done by increasing
it installed 25% for these countries by
using store listing experiments so now
they know where to operate it
target their spend to get the best
return on investment so one thing you've
told us and I heard this quite a lot for
partners was that while you think new
requisition report is great for
understanding your business I kept
getting asked is this actually good how
much opportunity exists to drive my
acquisition even further so late last
year we launched peer benchmarks peer
benchmarks help you see how your app
compares to similar apps in the same
category who use the same monetization
models so these peer benchmarks can be
seen in the user acquisition channel and
in the country breakdown channel and
this is really helpful for three reasons
number one it shows you exactly where
you need to focus your improvement
efforts for your conversion secondly it
can show you where you can make the
business case to invest more in
acquisitions and thirdly it can show you
where you can simply celebrate your team
success so let me share with you a
couple of partners who have used this
data to their advantage now you may be
familiar with fibre there are
communications app and they operate in a
pretty competitive market so it's really
important that they use all the levers
that their disposal to increase the top
of the funnel and get more users to
install their apps once we launch peer
benchmark viber could finally see what
good is and they knew what goals to set
themselves to reach for their install
conversion using this report 5 were able
to identify countries that were below
the peer benchmark one such example was
the UK and the US similarly you know
they seemed like sister countries right
they both speak English but as viper
discovered
in fact user behavior was quite
different and they saw that the UK
install conversion was much lower than
the Pearson it immediately allowed them
to jump on the problem and resolve it
using store listing experiments testing
the image logo descriptions to bring it
back up to path now I'm sure you're all
familiar with the Star Wars franchise
and you may also be familiar with the EA
game galaxy heroes which launched a a
while ago what they noticed was that
there were lots of people coming to
their page store listing but not as many
were installing the app as they expected
once we launched peer benchmarking EA
were able to see that actually the
problem was not the game but that the
category that the game sat in had a
lower conversion than other categories
in which EA has games and this led them
to think if they could change the
perception and the display of the game
could they increase conversion so peer
benchmarking gave EA the ability to
think not only in terms of category but
also country and as prompted them to
pivot the positioning of the game to
increase conversions it's had a profound
impact on the way that they approach top
of funnel marketing with this they're
able to create unique assets with
different categories and different
countries to increase conversions so if
you're a games company or you use in-app
purchase you might be thinking this is
fantastic I'm going to go home and dive
into my data and find ways I could
improve but how many of you here in the
audience and you can put your hand up if
you're also watching the live stream
have a subscription model or an ad
funded model or an e-commerce model
fantastic so there's quite a few of you
version one of the user acquisition
report was really useful for everyone
but perhaps geared more towards
developers with in-app purchase model
but like you here in the room today's
majority if you put your hand up we know
there are other really successful
business models where you really care
about building long term user
relationship right
so today I'm very excited to announce
the launch of version 2 of the funnel
which has been built specifically with
businesses like yours in mind who care
about user retention the report shows
retention periods which is a critical
metrics for understanding which channels
are bringing in your most loyal users
these retained installers are people who
have your app installed on at least one
of their devices this is your retained
install base so this and you can see the
percentages will show you what the
opportunity is to increase your user
retention using techniques like
notifications email or just increasing
your quality better yet one of my
favorites is the ability to export this
state of I CSV so now you'll be able to
extract your retained user I can see
people clapping it's great you go to
extract your retained user your install
and by conversion and your pier
benchmarks to help you manage your
business better and look for ways to
improve now I work a lot with
subscription partners from the news
industry through to health and fitness
and they are always asking me for more
data and student subscriptions that were
growing an important business model I'm
really happy to let you know that we
filled a report specifically for your
business now as much as I would like to
I'm not going to ruin the surprise if
you like to learn more about the
subscription report come back here 10:30
a.m. tomorrow morning to hear more about
that so in summary I know it from today
you're going to go away and you'll look
at your app and you'll be able to see
which channels are driving your most
valuable users which countries they're
coming from and you'll be able to see
where are the opportunities to increase
my install and buy conversions and how
can I increase my user retention all of
these reports are here to help you
optimize your growth strategies not just
for install that's a long-term value and
business success regardless of the way
you monetize we believe the acquisition
courts are there for you to help for
your business Thanks something so in
addition to the release dashboard and a
user acquisition report which give you
unique insights into your data as you
know in a play console we also have more
specialized dashboards for specific use
cases like crashes or Android vitals or
revenues and so on but we understand
that not all businesses are alike and
each of you may care about different
metrics am i care about doing analysis
in ways that we cannot predict so we
know many of you use our statistics page
but we also know that sometimes for
certain analysis you have to download
the CSV export and then craft your own
analysis using spreadsheets or other
external tool and we understand why how
for example could you understand whether
last year Black Friday sales went better
words of this year Black Friday sales
right or how could you compare or find
correlations between two different
metrics such as ratings and crashes so
if I take a step back and I think about
our old statistics page and there were a
number of issues you raised and you
asked us to fix it was sometimes blow to
note the date ranges you could pick
we're inflexible there was no
possibility of selecting multiple
metrics and also and it's not an
important point the latency of the
availability of the data was often
insufficient so we listened to your
feedback and we blowed it into our
product with a bunch of the launches we
had yesterday it begins with a new
statistics page and I would like to
introduce this to you today so here is
how it looks
at the first glance you can see that the
interface is much nicer and more
polished than before it has been
designed from the ground up from our
material design specifications with this
launch we are also including some new
metrics in the statistics page such as
for example the revenue metrics and also
the install update and uninstall events
which are
available on the release last one that
suzanne present before let me walk you
through some exciting features of this
page first you can now choose any date
range you want to visualize your data a
nice date picker is available on the top
right corner of the page you can there
are some pre selected time regions time
ranges but you can also pick a custom
one you want to visualize previously we
only we only had three third remember
correctly date ranges fixed that always
ended up today but now you being able to
choose any date ranges you can do some
analysis such as look at q4 2016 or
January of last year in addition when
you select a date range the new
statistics page by default will also
overlay a comparison of that matrix of
that date range with its most recent
history so for example if you pick the
last week of the the previous week of
the last week of data you will also see
that our relative to the previous week
overlaid on the chart as a dotted line
if you hold it on the chart a useful
tool tip will give you more data about
specific data points such as the exact
date but also how they compare
numerically so this feature will allow
you to do one of the comparisons that
the words mention is before for example
you could compare last year Black Friday
sales to this year very easily so our
partners at Expedia told us that they
love this feature they were actually
able to do very quickly another glance
either video or portable quarter
comparison analysis real quick and they
said that there is no other app
analytics tool that they know of the
dust is so easily and seamlessly another
cool feature is the ability of compare
two different metrics if you configure
your report by clicking the configure
report button you can now select an
additional metric to compare to so that
you can spot correlation of lack of
correlation between different metrics
such as install in revenue or as you can
see here crashes and ratings on the
chart the two different metrics will be
plotted with two different colors and as
you can see the date range comparison
will still be available and the tooltip
will be will include information about
both matrix and different date ranges so
this video will allow you to do quickly
to spot quickly correlation or lack of
correlation between different matrix we
spoken to moving corporators that had
early access to the statistics page for
their apartment and home rental search
up they were able to spot correlations
between crashes and on its own
effectively showing the impact of up
quality on the audience so now think
about this maybe many of you have a hard
time prioritizing fixing technical depth
over building new features right but
once you have this data in hand you
cannot build the case to work on that so
this is how you can use this data next
for some of our matrix available such as
the sole update and install event you
can now select to see hourly data
instead of daily with visualizing this
now reducing the latency of our matrix
has been about one of your loudest
concern and we've taken that really
seriously we've worked really hard on
that and I'm happy to announce that for
the matrix is all available available
hourly you shouldn't expect them to be
updated within a few hours in fact if
you log on the play console right now
for this matrix you should already see
data up for this morning
the hourly data will allow you to
observe hour-by-hour trends and also to
do analysis that was more difficult to
do before for example in case of offline
events like a TV ad and understanding
how this affect your metric your install
metric for example as you can see here
the comparison feature are still
available also when you look at the data
at an hourly granularity
last but not least if you remember the
previous starts page used to show you
the top 10 results for certain
breakdowns such as countries and device
if you wanted to dig deeper into data
you had to download the CSV export and
enough said observe those well we
improve the situation significant in the
new statistics page you still have the
top 10 results but you can now search
for any breakdown and as you can see the
table will also show a numerical
comparison between different metrics if
you have selected so and in addition you
can select specific breakdowns up to 2
and and see them plotted on the chart
and again as before all the comparison
feature I described before are still
available so you can do comparison
between multiple metrics between
multiple data ranges at an hourly
granularity for specific breakdowns
so Jacob the CEO of play lab who should
be in the room today ok so they are a
game developer company from Thailand and
he told us that she loved to have the
possibility of comparing multiple
metrics at a glance and without going
through spreadsheet and also seeing per
device or per country comparison so the
new subpage allows you to do most
sophisticated analysis much more quickly
than before
so to summarize the new system
statistics page is a powerful and
versatile to to analyze data entering
quickly what you could only achieve
before by downloading this data and
using our external tools or other
Canales we are publishing new metrics
such as revenue and install update and
uninstall events some of these metrics
will be available hourly and for these
metrics you should also expect a much
lower latency than before so I hope you
will enjoy using these features for your
business as much as we enjoy building
them for you thank you and back to
Suzanne
well thank you for taking us through the
new statistics based data and for the
business reporting walkthrough Tamsin so
I'd like to wrap up with some final
words we were very pleased to announce
all these features here today with the
release dashboard we give you visibility
into the health of your release with the
acquisition report you can see how
efficient your marketing channels are
for additional business models and
finally with the new statistics pages
we're giving you a much more flexible
way to look at your own data together
these features make clay data work even
harder for you and helps you build
successful apps on play so thank you
very much
[Music]